this is truly one of the legendary
estates of Beverly Hills
I'm Jeff Hyland and I'm the listing
agent of Beverly house this is the most
expensive estate for sale in the United
States
there are five structures on the
property 30 bedrooms 40 bathrooms two
tennis courts three swimming pools the
Art Deco nightclub is perfectly suited
for nighttime entertainment this wine
cellar is unique because the wine is
chilled behind these glass doors you can
see here in the billiard room the
intricate Spanish hand carved ceiling
brought back from one of the Castillo's
in Spain somebody called me said well
what else can you show me I have to say
this is it
the honeymoon for John and Jaclyn
Kennedy to me stands out as one of the
highlights its most famously known as
the home for William Randolph Hearst the
most important newspaper magnate in the
whole world
the Beverly House is is very famous for
the movies that have been filmed here
The Godfather
where the Hollywood producer wakes up in
the middle of night and the horse's head
is in the bed and the swimming pool is
also probably is famously recognized
from The Bodyguard
with Whitney Houston and Kevin Costner
whoever buys the house is going to pay
cash there are maybe two thousand people
around the world who are ready willing
and able to purchase this estate there's
certainly nothing anywhere of the
stature that's available it is iconic
it's unique and one-of-a-kind that you
cannot duplicate